when you take the shahada all of your
former sins are
erased endorsed and featured as a
natural alternative to synthetic
pharmaceutical drugs in the celebrity
Angels dear doctor magazine reignite the
Flames of passion in your marriage with
these spectacular male and female libido
orgasm and stamina enhancing pills men
experience a huge boost in vitality and
last much longer women ReDiscover the
Ecstasy of heightened climatic pleasures
and passion lost to the de grind unleash
the full potential of your marriage with
these amazing pills your ticket to a
deeper more fulfilling connection with
your spouse is one click away get yours
now links in the description box
below brothers and sisters and dear
friends so and T was on an interview
with P Morgan towards the end of the
interview or should I say he ended real
fast he invited him to Islam but here
was his reaction when you take to
shahada all of your former sins are
erased and I actually encourage you to
find find the light and convert to Islam
Andrew Tate thank you very much so guys
subh as you can see one thing that you
need to love about brother Andrew Tate
nobody's perfect like any of us but
alhamdulillah at least because the
prophet told us convey from me even if
it's a verse now the fact that he is
inviting him to Islam yes and telling
him about Islam and telling him that if
you accept Islam all your sins will be
forgiven Subhan Allah to me is profound
because he didn't have to do that if he
didn't really care about the religion
and it was just something that he was
just using he would never do that and he
invited he invited Pi M and we should
but it was very funny that at that
moment of time that Pi Moran had to end
the interview and say thank you very
much and this shows us something really
profound we are not in control of the
hearts nobody can force anybody to
accept Islam nobody's da is good enough
that he gets shahad this that these are
matters that is praising should be
praising Allah not oh this guy's a die
and he's got hundreds of shahad it's
Allah that deserves the praise you are
not doing anything special for that
matter you are a means Allah will guide
them regardless I know a situation of
brothers from AA who've gone to a
specific Island and met a person who's
got the first mosque there and he an IM
and he came to Islam just via a pamphlet
yeah Allah will guide with or without
you we ask that Allah subhana wa tala
allows us to get the rewards that it
comes like it's like giving Sak Allah's
going to give their risk regardless to
the poor people we just ask that Allah
that it touches our hand before it
reaches them that we benefit from it cuz
Allah doesn't need us for it to reach
them Subhan Allah same with the shahada
and I praise brother Andrew may Allah
bless him for inviting P Moran to Islam
he rejected it and it will be on him on
that he didn't even open up to the idea
and just shut the conversation may Allah
bless you guys and preach The Message of
Islam people are coming to Islam just by
the Palestinian cause of seeing their
plight seeing how strong and resistant
resilient they are with their faith and
Iman hundreds many people of influence
are coming to Islam that's all I wanted
to say may Allah bless you guys make du
for PE more as well um and our brother
Andrew T may Allah keep him firm and
invite your neighbors and friends to
Islam